[Music]
welcome back
halloween is filled with ghosts goblins
and ghouls
but do you know what can be truly
terrifying
things are bound to get messy on
halloween but guess what
when it comes to stains nothing scares
me
because i'm a stand for stains that's
right
i am completely obsessed with all things
stain removal
this is my happy place it's like oh my
gosh
this is just i wanted to help some
viewers who are truly haunted by their
halloween stained dilemmas first
up here's natasha hi drew
my name is natasha i'm a wife and mom to
a three-year-old daughter
arya and for halloween she is dressing
as a
police officer she has refused to take
off her costume
in fact she got marshmallow spread all
over the front of it i am nervous to
touch it out of here i'll make it worse
and i can't find this costume
natasha i totally get you my daughter
frankie will
only wear her nightgown it's like
literally we show up places and people
like oh
your daughter's in an account i'm like i
know
um okay so here i'm actually gonna take
a little um basically a scissor that's
for
like nose hairs a tiny baby scissors and
i'm gonna start
i'm going flat on the fabric do not
point the
scissors down i'm going to go flat on
the fabric and i'm just going to lift up
whatever's like really sticky and hard
um i
yeah but we're not cutting the fabric
okay
then also i have two different styles of
tweezers here
yeah that's right i have the sharp
needle
so basically you can start and listen
you know
it's going to be time consuming but can
you think of a better way to spend time
natasha i can't
so basically i want you to start with a
tweezer
and a nail scissors you can also use ice
which will harden it and then you can
like uh i had a butter knife somewhere
around here oh there it is
this is also a great tool so this look
at that do you see that you can harden
it with the ice
and then scrape because this isn't
really about a stain
this is more about liftage uppage
of a certain substance so it's a little
different so for me
i would pluck cut
ice and butter knife and see where that
takes you
okay next uh
who is next let's see jennifer
what's your stain dilemma
hi true my name is jennifer we
are obsessed with halloween tonight i
made
spaghetti and eyeballs for dinner tomato
sauce
got all over my favorite halloween place
mats what do i
do
i'm so excited and hot and bothered
right now i can't even handle it
i'm so turned on you don't understand
tomato sauce
like the best stain okay here we go now
i am going to put my goggles on because
my brother from another
brother um no brother from another
mother chris miller was like
you need gloves and goggles for this
because
listen jennifer here's the deal you've
got nothing to lose
okay so we're gonna go real hardcore
on this mother if you know what i mean
all right here you go
this is a bowl of pure clorox
that's right you heard me it's pure
clorox
all right and we're gonna just dunk it
yeah we're gonna go right in there with
it yep
that's right we're gonna go right in
there now
we're going to dilute this with water
right away
so because clorox will basically eat
your fabric that's right it'll eat right
through it isn't that awesome
yeah it is okay then i've got my plastic
thing
this tool is fantastic it's abrasive and
i've already tested it
it does not distribute color onto the
thing because the truth is
your tool can leave a bigger stain like
if
anyone here has tried to remove things
with an sos pad well you know what i
mean
don't get me wrong sos pads are very
sexy but not great for stain removal
okay then you're going to get this
abrasive brush that does not
distribute and then you're just going to
work it out and you've got to work
quickly here
because that clorox is like right
through your fabric
and then we're going to go go go
yeah oh god it's just all up in those
fibers
now this is the opposite advice i gave
on the last stain removal thing which is
you want to go
soft as a bunny and a field of cotton
this is like
texas chainsaw massacre you know what i
mean come on it's halloween
you got to get leather face up in this
immediately dump into a tub of water
which i'm gonna do right here
okay tub of water tub of water then
you want to immediately get it in
to well let's see how the stain is doing
first
i'm so excited okay look at how much
better that is
now you want to get this sucker right
into the washing machine
and you want to dilute it with like i
would do a full cup of detergent and
just this
to give it the love that's right baby i
love stains
[Music]
you